the tragedy I see is people work really
hard on their books and then they pay
attention to it for a week and then they
move on to the next that book is there
for the rest of your life
if no one reads your book you've written
a journal yeah I stole that line from my
friend Richard it's a good one it's my
same friend who said he feels so sorry
for people the week of their book
release
um I think that
without an audience
how audacious is it for you to think
people are going to read your book I was
that audacious I just thought well it's
out there obviously people are going to
care and the reality is you've got to
spend time nurturing finding your
audience making them aware of you making
sure they care about what your topic is
and then you actually write something
that you know that people want to read
and if you are reticent to go put
yourself out there again cool that just
means your book may be a journal it may
be a book no one reads if you want
people to read it you better be putting
yourself out there not just once but
over and over and over again telling
them about it
why do you say TV appearances don't sell
books
does not sell books because like let's
say
somebody on my podcast just said this to
me the other day let's say someone has
an exercise book and they go on The
Today Show and they go this is how
you're supposed to be doing sit-ups and
pull-ups somebody watching that is like
oh cool why do they need the book the
person just explained how to do it
a person has to hear about your book
between 8 and 15 times before they buy
it so if you're on the Today Show that's
a really big deal that's one out of 8 or
15 times
as opposed to a podcast where you are in
someone's ear maybe they're lying in bed
maybe they're walking they're do like
you are there with them it's a really
really intimate medium
people like if you're watching The Today
Show it's just sort of this like passive
thing it's on podcast you made an active
you had an active desire to listen to
that you are either so invested in that
host that you really trust what the host
says or you were searching and you want
to learn how to do something so it was
such it's the statistics on how much
better uh authors can sell books on
podcasts over books are ridiculous
how important are pre-sales
in the traditional publishing World
pre-sales used to be so important
because it determined what bookstores
were going to order now that bookstores
aren't that important
um they're less important here's why it
matters the way it works is let's say
your book is coming out in a month and
you're telling people now every single
book sale that happens between now and
that first week counts towards your
first week sales so if you're trying to
make the New York Times list
um and you can sell 10 000 copies
between your pre-order time and the
launch that's great for most people it
doesn't matter at all I am a big fan of
like the stealth launch where you
actually don't tell people the date
until the book is out because most of
our book sales happen on Amazon for
better or worse and the Amazon algorithm
really favors new books it really gives
a lot of juice to new books and and the
way it starts to work is if your book
you want people to buy your book that
are already interested in your topic so
that Amazon starts doing that what they
call the also bots so it'll say
customers who bought this also bought
this this this and this so
um that launch week Book Sales matter to
me a lot more than pre-sales
what can an author do to boost first
week sales
um the best thing you can do to boost
first week sales is be everywhere but
first week matters so much less than
first month or first year I think a lot
of people think oh my God it has to be
this great success out of the gate
because that's what traditional it's for
traditional publishing
your book doesn't sell that first week
they're done they're moving on when
we're not dealing with that your book is
there for the rest of your life and the
tragedy I see is people work really hard
on their books and then they pay
attention to it for a week and then they
move on to the next that book is there
for the rest of your life so I say yeah
try to be everywhere all at once first
week but then try to layer promotion if
you have podcast interviews see if one
can come out week two another one week
three if you have people supporting you
by sending out newsletter lists like
and as Amazon likes that a lot what
Amazon doesn't love is a whole bunch of
sales one day and then nothing you know
drip it out that's going to be the best
thing for everyone so the drip method
yes I like that don't waste time on
forwards celebrity endorsements and Book
Sales
yeah I said that yeah I um I see so many
people obsess over I'm gonna get so and
so to do my blurb and I judge them so
much until I became that person there
was like this one person and I'm like I
know I can get her to do the blurb and
no one cares I myself have never bought
a book because somebody blurbed it ever
ever ever so it's wonderful to have that
sort of social proof of well-known
people endorsing you but it is not the
most important thing forwards are great
if you happen to know a very famous
person who happens to know you well and
be associated with your topic that's a
pretty rare circumstance
otherwise you shouldn't do it the nice
thing about a forward is that on Amazon
they're listed as the co-author so we
have a book where Magic Johnson wrote
the forward so anybody searching for a
book by Magic Johnson this book is going
to come up
but I see people just sort of being like
Oh so-and-so like do my forward and it
doesn't even make sense
and then last but not least Book Sales
uh why don't Book Sales matter
because Book Sales you're making pennies
on the dollar if you are strategic about
it you are book sales accounting pennies
when you could be literally counting
Millions if you have an offer embedded
into your book or you your book shows
that you are the world's leading
Authority on this so people want to hire
you it's just focusing on Book Sales is
focusing on the wrong thing and when you
say offer you mean a link or a QR code
that could then hire you out for
something yeah yeah I mean just I think
think of your book as your calling card
it is your you know 200 pages to go
convince the world that you know about
this topic and it's not it's not like a
crass business thing it's just you
should be paid a living wage and if
you're relying on Book Sales you're
never going to be unless you're JK
Rowling
would it work for fiction too
well no I mean it really doesn't that's
kind of
um it's really hard as a fiction author
to have a business that supports your
book I lucked into it with party girl
because it was I I was suddenly being
considered an expert in addiction and
Recovery
um but but normally a novel is not going
to lend you expertise